all right welcome back to game on vegas
it was a battle for the fremont cannon
reno visiting
of course the new palace there were fans
there inside unlv
reno facility was gorgeous they
negotiated with the health department
two thousand fans to witness history
someday it'll be full of fans it'll be a
lot of fun but yesterday it wasn't so
much fun for the rebels
and those 2 000 fans sitting inside
because it was reno
who took the lead and they never gave it
up and they beat unlv 37-19 of course
marcus arroyo this is his first
experience as a head coach inside a
legion stadium
but it was reno with just too much in
the final 37-19
after the game the coaches talked about
this and we're but we're hurting
uh you know i think that that's the
thing that
culture that we've gotta understand is
is we gotta play good football to beat
good football teams
and uh we're not into uh not into moral
victories we gotta execute better on all
sides of the ball
and uh we've gotta we've gotta come
together and go ahead and rewind this
and put it back and
play it tomorrow and make sure that
we're um we're really detailed in
finding out exactly what it is we can do
to improve
because we've got another week coming up
and uh
and it's not going to stop so it's a
special game for me
i mean whenever you get a chance to play
for the cannon
and it's a special game and uh you know
i
i spent two of the best years of my life
working for the oakland raiders and
went to the super bowl was around guys
great players like rich gannon and
charles woodson
jerry rice tim brown and uh
and al davis al davis is a giant of
of a man in football a hall of fame
owner and coach and um
i work for him he was my boss and i
learned a lot from him and i loved being
a raider
and so you know to play the first
college game here in this stadium
you know that honors al davis and the
oakland raiders
it meant a lot to me and we wanted to
win it you know we wanted to
win this game in this building on this
day
and it was important for nevada
it's important for a university it was
important for a football program
all right so once again unlv drops their
second game now rebels hosting fresno
this weekend at the stadium now still
ahead here on game on